tensions musk plus chips and cars here
are three things to watch at the G20
meeting
as geopolitical tensions rise State
leaders from around the world will
gather in Bali President Joe Biden and
Xi Jinping are sent to meet on the
sidelines of The Summit in what would
mark their first sit down one face we
likely won't see Vladimir Putin who
hopes to avoid potential confrontations
with other leaders over his invasion of
Ukraine
trade tensions are reaching a fever
pitch ahead of the G20 from chips to
electric vehicles President Biden's
policies to boost EV production in the
U.S has angered allies in Europe and
South Korea while his efforts to block
Chinese ship development has sent chills
through an already battered
semiconductor industry what's critical
is that world leaders are staring down a
potential Global recession we'll see if
that will spur them to try and soften
the blow by reaching some agreements on
trade
plus the richest man in the world Elon
Musk is also headed to Bali according to
Indonesia he's scheduled to deliver a
speech at an international Gathering of
Business Leaders on the sidelines of a
group of 20 leading countries earlier in
the year Indonesian president Joko
Widodo urged mosque to make his country
a manufacturing hub for Tesla to make
both its batteries and cars
make sure to follow us at quick take for
all the latest updates
[Music]